Hello I’m Daven Hiskey, you’re watching
the TodayIFoundOut Youtube channel.
In the video today, we’re looking at the
origin of the word blackmail and the much
lesser known buttockmail.
"Blackmail" has its roots in the early 16th
century, first used by English farmers living
on the England/Scotland border.
It derives from the Middle English word "male"
which itself is thought to derive from the
Old English word "mal", meaning "lawsuit,
terms, bargaining, agreement".
Over time, this word evolved to "Male" which
in Middle English roughly translated to either
"Rent" or "Tribute".
As such, the rent paid by a farmer living
on the Scottish border was known as "Silver
Rent/Mail" because it was normally paid in
silver.
This gave rise to "White Money" or "White
Rent", and eventually "whitemail".
When certain Scottish chieftains (and various
brigands) noticed all these well to do farmers
going about their business without someone
threatening them for money, they decided to
start threatening them for money in return
for not razing their farm to the ground and
destroying all their livestock.
Those forcing the tribute would also then
offer their protection to the farmers from
others who might try something similar.
Farmers almost immediately began referring
to this secondary rent they were being forced
to pay as "black rent" or "blackmail".
Etymologists aren't sure where the "black"
part of blackmail came from.
Seemingly the most obvious theory is simply
due to the connotations black had with evil.
But the most obvious answer and the correct
one aren't necessarily the same, and lacking
direct evidence, many other theories have
popped up.
The most probable of the bunch is by Charles
McKay in the Dictionary of Lowland Scots (1888)
who claimed it derives from the Gaelic blathaich,
meaning "to protect", so "protection rent".
Whatever the case, in 1814, the Scottish playwright,
Sir Walter Scott gave the world perhaps the
most detailed explanation of what blackmail
back in those days entailed.
In Scott's historical novel Waverley, blackmail
(written then as "black-mail") is described
as follows.
“A sort of protection-money that Low-Country
gentlemen and heritors,
lying near the Highlands, pay to some Highland
chief, that he may neither
do them harm himself, nor suffer it to be
done to them by others”
Scott also mentions that if a person paying
this protection money comes to harm or suffered
a loss at the hands of another raider, the
person they were paying would endeavour to
cover their losses, usually by stealing replacements
from someone who wasn't paying them protection
money.
This all brings us to yet another form of
"-mail" that was popular from about the 16th
century through the 19th that, purely for
its amusing sounding nature, we'd like to
bring back into common usage in some form
or another: buttock-mail.
Given what you now know of "-mail", if you
guessed that "buttock-mail" was some form
of payment in order to keep things quiet about
your having a good time with someone's buttock,
you actually wouldn't be that far off.
In fact (in Scotland), buttock-mail was a
sort of a tax introduced in 1595 which was
enforced by the church courts.
Essentially, if you had sex outside of wedlock,
often with a prostitute (hence the "buttock"
part, which was a slang for prostitute), and
you were a Presbyterian in Scotland, you would
often be given the choice of the Stool of
Repentance or paying buttock-mail to stop
from having to stand on a stool in front of
everyone and get berated by your local minister
for your lustful actions.
While the latter, perhaps, doesn't sound so
bad to modern thinking compared to having
to pay a hefty tax to keep things quiet, without
the option of buttock-mail, or if one couldn't
afford it, people are known to have killed
themselves rather than have to face the Stool
of Repentance and the "fornicator" label that
would follow them
in the aftermath.